كيف نتخلص من ملابسنا القديمة ليس
صديقًا للبيئة تمامًا
وفقًا لتقرير عام 2014 الصادر عن
وكالة حماية البيئة ، فإن 80٪ من
ملابسنا وأحذيتنا القديمة ينتهي بها المطاف في
مقالب القمامة وأن البوليستر الرخيص
يستغرق وقتًا أطول في التحلل من
القطن أو الصوف.  بالنسبة إلى شركة النسيج الحيوي ،
تأتي كل من الخيوط الخضراء من
مصدر غير عادي حيث كان
مصدر الإلهام لهذا الحرير الدقيق يأتي
من سنوات من الإحباط في الغالب من
العلماء وخريجي
حرير العنكبوت بدون عناكب ، إنها ليست
فكرة جديدة ، لقد مرت حوالي 50 عامًا
ولكن لم يكن أحد  يمكن أن تجعله حرير العنكبوت
قويًا بشكل مدهش ، مما يجعله في
مصنع يبدأ بعزل البروتينات
التي تجعله صعبًا للغاية بحيث يعيدون تكوينها
هنا في هذه الخزانات باستخدام الخميرة والسكر ، حيث
نقوم بضخ السكر
باستمرار في عيد الفصح الذي يأكلونه فيه.
الأكسجين من ثاني أكسيد الكربون ،
إنهم يصنعون المزيد من الخميرة
ويقومون بصنع الحرير في نهاية هذا
سوف يحصد هذا
وينقي الحرير فقط.  ay من كل شيء آخر ،
هذه عملية تستغرق ثلاثة أيام ،
اتضح أن هذه القبعة في الواقع هي
نسيج أخف بنسبة 10 في المائة وحوالي 30 في
المائة أكثر دفئًا ، لذا تعلم هذا
بالصدفة ، ما وجدناه
مستخدمًا للتكنولوجيا الجديدة بكمية هائلة
من الإمكانات أمامنا ، هناك الكثير
من الأشياء الرائعة حول هذا الموضوع ،
ولا نفهم حتى الآن أننا نتعلم
على طول الطريق بينما يستخدم الترباس الخميرة
لإعادة إنشاء حرير العنكبوت في المروج الحديثة ،
يستخدمون الخميرة لزراعة الجلد إذا
كنت تعتقد  حول
اللبنات الأساسية للجلد وهو الكولاجين
أنت وأنا مكونان من الكولاجين ، فأنت تعلم أن
إبر الجلود والكولاجين تحافظ على
وجهك وأنت تعرف أنه ناعم ومفعم
وشبابي بشكل صحيح ولكن بدلاً من الاضطرار إلى
الاعتماد على الحيوان لصنع هذا الكولاجين ،
فإننا نستخدم  معظم التقنيات المتطورة
من حيث الهندسة الوراثية
للخميرة عندما نحصل على
الخميرة لدينا لجعل كليتنا أو تعرف
أي نوع من الكولاجين في الواقع
لأنك لا تقيد أي شيء
حقيقي  قيود أخرى غير قدرتنا
على وضع الحمض النووي